[Musique]
on déplore que le gouvernement charest
choisit la voie de la répression plutôt
que la voie de la discussion
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
comme ça bravent la loi c'est très
impressionnant
[Applaudissements]
tout s'est déroulé dans leur note que ce
qu'on peut voir d'ici a pas eu trop de
problèmes
on a laissé les manifestants continuer
leur marche pendant de longues minutes
on pense bien que madame marois n'aura
aucune difficulté
ce choix le prochain gouvernement sera
formé bien sûr par le parti québécois de
devenir un pays souverain
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une autre fusillade aux etats-unis nous
oblige ce soir à mettre des mots sur
l'horreur l'âge des petites victimes
cette fois nous laisse sans voix
imaginez le choc qu'ils éprouvent ce
soit cette petite communauté
le vote est pas assez et ça y est c'est
terminé et ça vient tout juste de se
finir en fait
résultat final 159 pour en faveur du
projet de loi en faveur de l'abolition
du registre centre encontre évidemment
la majorité des votes pour ce sont des
conservateurs tiré que les témoignages
qui faisaient les roms seraient les
vérités premier témoin entendu devant la
commissaire charbonneau un ancien haut
fonctionnaire a fait qui est venu dire
que les magouilles et la corruption la
savez-vous on a parlé beaucoup mais ça
date de bien longtemps c'est ce qu'il a
dit en fait il est remonté jusqu'aux
années 60
après dix jours de cavale celui qui
serait à l'origine d'un des meurtres les
plus sordides de l'histoire canadienne a
finalement été arrêté dans un café
internet de berlin en allemagne
deux passagers ont été retrouvés sains
et saufs ce soir à bord de l'épave du
paquebot qui a fait naufrage au large de
la toscane hier des dizaines de
personnes manquent toujours à l'appel
oui en me disant
[Musique]
ce jeune canadien qui avait 15 ans
lorsqu'il a été capturé a été rapatrié
en 12 ce matin c'est dans la plus grande
discrétion qu'omar khadr est rentré au
canada